Today's topic. Oh boy, we gotta do a part two, apparently,
cuz there's more audio. Ooh. There's more sauce.
Who would've thought not company to bring us the truth on this topic is the
daily mail. I.
You can please tell people that it was a fair fight and see what the ju see what
the jury and judge think. Tell the world Johnny, tell them Johnny death.
I joined up man. I'm I'm a victim too mine. And I, you know,
it's a fair fight and sees how many people believe or side with you.
It doesn't matter if for faired though. Exactly.
Because you're bit you're bigger and you're stronger. And so when I say that,
I thought you could kill me. That doesn't mean you counter with you also, uh,
that, that you lost.
Your own finger. Listen, the fact that I'm bigger and stronger,
you doesn't give you the right to cut off my finger.
What am I listening to? What did, what did she say? What am I listening to?
What did she say?
She said that I've been saying this for three years and I've been getting
dragged in the mud by a lot of people who say Abba,
you are anti woman are anti this. You are anti that.
And I'm like, no,
I'm just about the truth that whenever I've seen stuff initiated between
couples, it is major of times.
It's always going to be the woman that initiates and the world wants to ignore
this fact. And I'm like, no, you guys been doing this.
And I also want to ask this question.
If women are always initiating these kinds of situations and they're raising
children, kids see their parents fighting and women always initiating,
what do you think that does to their psyche?
Huh? Where they're inoculated in a society where women feel it's fine to be
physically abusive towards people, but they can,
you should never hit a woman. But so what that happens is this.
So what you going to do? What you going to do? Huh? Huh? I,
you hit me. I can't in the number of times. I see that, someone.
But here's the thing is that now these kids are watching these parents, right?
And they're seeing that whenever the woman is stressed out,
whenever she has a problem, she engages in physical act.
The kids internalize that as an adequate response,
there's studies to back this up,
that kids who are raised in households with physical contact is a solution to
problems.
These kids are far more likely to engage in that behavior when they become
adults. And I've been saying this for so long and everyone has laughed about it.
And they'd be like, you guys are just being big babies. And I'm like, okay,
cool. Now people are losing their fingers. People are,
you're seeing hearing audio tapes of this stuff. And people are like, I,
oh my God. But it's so are gonna reason. Some people are gonna defend that.
And that's of course, and that, and that is crazy to me. The are gonna of,
I'm gonna stop arguing with people because when you confront people with facts,
people don't like to have to,
unthink what they already know and what they already perceive
as the truth. Cuz they're narrative cause of the narrative and it's hard.
People want to be right. And I get that. Yep.
So when you bring up facts to people, it is very hard to change your mind.
Even if you have facts, it, it, it clashes. It's a big clash.
Do you know what part of the brain that is, is because for human beings,
it's more important to be part of a tribe yep.
Than it is for them to be logical. Yep. Right?
So this is like goes back to like ancient times. Whereas like absolutely.
If you were outcasted from your tribe, you basically, you would die. Exactly.
Because you wouldn't have access to food, shelter, all that stuff. And so we,
as a programmed instinct want togetherness more than we want to
be logical. Mm-hmm <affirmative>,
it's the same reason why the media who was so outspoken about Amber,
her and her allegations, ain, ain.
Right now they have not said a single word about what she's saying right now.
And these audio tapes. So let me get those straight. Was that crickets?
That's what it is. So Amber, when she had had photos,
right?
When she had these really weird videos that didn't showcase anything y'all
reported on it every day.
But the moment literal audio of her saying yes, I did.
These things comes out.
Every single one of these news media outlets have said nothing.
Some of even said on Twitter that like there's people were saying you, well,
it looks like it was mutual. And I'm like, are you serious?
Is that what you heard in the audio tapes?
Where's your journalistic integrity where you started this story,
but you didn't follow up on it when you details that contradicted what your
origin said, come out. Where is your integrity? That's my question. You can't,
you can't say when you doing journalism,
you can said that you're wrong because you report the truth.
So once you said on, on, you said on one narrative,
you can't go back on what you said here.
I'm just trying to point out the fact of why I said call 9 1 1 because I was,
you are, you had your hands on me after you threw a phone and my face.
And I gotten crazy in the past and I truly thought I
need to stop this madness before I get hurt.
Oh my God. And I never think about myself that way.
I never defend myself that way. I never see myself as a victim. It's your.
Fault. You know, I never see myself as the victim. It's your fault. You know,
I never see myself as the victim, but I'm the victim.
You believe you believe I'm gonna, you believe I'm gonna be
April. Do you believe you're?
Do you believe you? Me physically?
Do I physically believe? I mean, do I believe I <laugh>?
Yeah. Listen. Do I physically believe? Yeah, no, no, no. Listen,
if you ask someone a question and they, and they repeat it,
it's like when you ask it's like, yo, where were you tonight? Who? Cynthia? No.
No. You mean who? Who? Cynthia? Who?
Cynthia.
They took all that time to process information so they could come up with a lie.
She's thinking right now and now she'll come up with some answer. I ice,
get paids. She's she's skating right now. Ice get paids, ice. Get paids, bro.
She's flown through the sky. She's in 2051.
Yes. Do you know?
I'm 115? Well, not anymore, but I was 115.
I don't care. I don't care if my neighbor's here. Wow.
Who's that girl. Who's who's that? Who's that girl. Yeah. Who's that girl.
I saw you kiss last night. Who's that girl that you saw me kiss. Like, you know,
I work hard all day. Yeah. All night. Yes, yes,
yes, yes. That's exactly what I was thinking.
Be that is exactly what I was thinking. You know, I work hard all day,
all night, sweat,
all the food I put on the table for us to be able to you go to ask me who's
that girl. Yeah. Did you?
Yes. Do you know?
I'm 115? Well, not anymore, but I was 115 pounds.
I'm hundred 15 pound woman in New York. I had the capacity.
You that's not the question. That's not the question.
Yes, my, my man Johnny's over it. That's not the question. Don't be deflecting.
Don't be deflecting off what I said. That's not the question. That's a yes,
no question. You know, that's a yes, no question.
You know what? This is like, wow. This is,
this is what perpetuates Weinstein culture. It's like when Weinstein like, oh,
a woman says, oh I got Weinstein. And then people are like,
what did you like it? She was wet. What does that have to do with anything?
Has nothing, nothing to do with anything. Have.
I ever been, have I ever been able to knock you off of your feet? You started.
Did I? Did I drag you back to my room? Did I ping you against a wall? No.
When I, when you saw, when you guys saw me with your friends,
wast everything fine.
It is the exact same client of thinking that you guys denounce all the time to
her standards. She has to knock him off balance
that that's what a thing I'm about to start punching a whole bunch of bros and
keeping him in place. Didn't hit you. <laugh>
are you talking about me? That's not even, that's not an argument. These.
You you're gonna get on the stand Johnny and say she started it really.
I have never been able to overpower these.
That's the difference between me and you. Why did you try?
And that's the difference that the whole world and the jury and the judge will
see is that there's a very big.
Difference between me and you. So this is, this is what we mean.
When we say that there are women out here who will purposefully use these
movements to their benefit,
because she's well aware of how the world perceives men and how the world
perceives any idea of like aggression towards men. And so she says, no,
one's gonna believe you try telling a jury that.
So she's well aware as she's crafting these lies in this narrative of hers,
how she's going to be perceived as a sympathetic victim.
She understands this dynamic.
And so she's using it to her advantage to blackmail him at this point.
And I'm telling you guys, she's not the only one.
There are many women who are like this. Some people think guys,
you guys are being irrationally afraid.
Here's my <affirmative> most men in this world are not aggressive.
Most men in this world will never touch you ladies,
not against your will anyways.
And yet when you guys walk home late at night and you're on a street and you're
afraid, I understand why you guys are afraid. I get,
I understand the vulnerable position that you guys are put in.
Even if most men are not gonna do stuff,
it all needs one time to really wreck and be a problem in that same token.
A lot of men are worried about women lying on them because of the fact that we
know it does happen. We are either have friends or we've heard stories.
And so we internalize that fear.
So if we can sympathize and understand your fear when you walk home late at
night and there's a dude behind you, you should be able to understand our fear.
When we think that a woman may lie on us. So here's the irony.
This is that five days,
five days before this audio came out,
Amber heard was at a woman's March. Oh,
in Los Angeles giving the greatest speech. That is the cring.
Here we go. One.
In which I used to live,
one that remind did me that despite all that I had done and fought for
all I had said and survived B before and through my
very public heart. Wrenchingly lonely battle for justice that I,
a woman would never truly see it.
That my voice didn't couldn't fully
count that despite what it took for me to stand up
and finally raise my voice and to speak my truth.
It did. Yeah. Your truth. Not the truth,
because truth is actually a lie.
It didn't really matter.
The deck was stacked against me in ways I couldn't even begin
to imagine. Is she reading poetry? I,
instead of a support respect,
I would be instead with hostility, skepticism and shame.
You believe wait, isn't that literally what you said was gonna happen to Johnny.
If he came forward and said what he said,
isn't that literally what you said to Johnny,
go ahead and try to tell everyone what, what happened? Who are they think?
Are they gonna believe? Who are they gonna fight with? So, wow.
Okay. The level you are bugging, you are a giant.
Guber. Yes. Yes.
Enough is enough times up me too. Our lives matter.
It is worth fighting for a world where things are better where things are more
fair for everyone.
Except Johnny Depp, except men, Hollywood woke to Vista.
Just so out of touch. That's all. I'm gonna say anything else.
There was a moment. There was a time where I was, oh man, man, rights activists.
Shut the shut up. Just shut up. Shut up. Okay.
Frige <laugh> the more and more I see it. And I see this go.
It is spiraling outta hand. This is just to all the people that should be.
Okay?
The people that should be the most is actual a feminist.
You're the one that should be talking because she's trashing your movement right
now. She's a detriment to your movement. You should be very loud on her,
but you're not saying anything. And she's the one trashing your movement,
but you're gonna say nothing and stand by her. If you see something,
say something, but now you see something, you all say nothing,
that's it for today's video.
All.